[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily a
monumental ruling by the supreme court
of the united states what the justices
rule on the biden administration's
vaccine mandate and the deadly michigan
school shooting what a new civil lawsuit
alleges led up to the shooting plus it's
like we have no voices
it took for something of this magnitude
for us to have a voice civil rights
attorney benjamin crump backs a family's
wrongful death lawsuit after a
13-year-old florida boy is killed but
first the latest in the deadly waukesha
christmas parade investigation in fact
mr brooks could have just simply stopped
the car to avoid striking anybody or any
object correct correct long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the deadly waukesha christmas
parade suspect will now head to trial
after a judge rules there is enough
evidence against accused daryl brooks
this comes as 71 new charges are added
to brook's criminal complaint he now
faces a total of 77 charges in the
december attack
six people were killed and more than 50
were injured in november 21st of last
year when a red ford escape suv drove
onto a blocked off road in the middle of
the annual christmas parade the driver
ran over dozens of people after breaking
through barricades along the parade
route brooks is charged with six counts
of first degree intentional homicide six
counts of hit and run resulting in death
two counts of felony bail jumping two
counts of misdemeanor battery and 61
counts of first degree recklessly
endangering safety at a hearing on
friday brooks appeared in the courtroom
in a red orange jumpsuit sitting
alongside his attorneys hands in his lap
waiting to hear if there was sufficient
evidence for the case to go to trial one
of the officers who witnessed the
incident first hand testified to seeing
brooks driving that suv
were you positioned directly in front of
the vehicle yes i was
and what happened
uh the vehicle continued driving into me
i'd say it was a slow speed at that
point eventually the vehicle made
contact with me and i was pounding on
the hood uh yelling for it to stop which
it did not
could you see anybody inside the vehicle
um at that point um i could not see the
person real clearly but as the vehicle
continued pushing through me i was um
my position changed to the side of the
vehicle where i was directly outside the
driver's side window the driver of that
vehicle do you see that person present
in the courtroom here today yes i do
could you identify him please you sit at
the seating at the defense table dressed
allen red
you know the name of that person
daryl brooks and uh
you positively identify mr brooks as the
driver of the vehicle at this point yes
i do there is ample evidence on each of
those to show sir that you probably
committed a felony or felonies within
the jurisdiction of this court and based
upon that i am going to bind you over
for trial
brook's arraignment is set for february
11th joining us today is legal analyst
dina dahl and terry austin dina as the
charges begin to stack against brooks
what do you predict will happen in this
case trial or plea deal
i imagine this will go to trial because
the prosecution because of how
horrible this crime was and how
important it was to the community
doesn't really have much of an incentive
to offer him a plea deal and they have a
lot of evidence as well and death
penalty is off the table here wisconsin
doesn't have it it's just monetary life
so there wouldn't really be much they
would offer him anyway
i so although he
may want a deal i don't see the
prosecution offering it yeah the defense
at best maybe try to knock off one or
two of those charges maybe more but with
77 charges that's quite a lot terry thus
far we have not heard any evidence of a
motive in this case do you think we will
see a mental illness defense
i do absolutely you know wisconsin law
allows someone to claim mental illness
if at the time of the act he lacked the
capacity to appreciate right from wrong
and we heard during the preliminary
hearing that detective casey testified
that the defendant failed to stop even
though he and other officers were trying
to get it to stop so i think the defense
is going to claim that the defendant did
not understand what was going on his
mother actually brian claimed also that
he suffered from mental illness and that
the system never offered to help him so
i absolutely expect that we'll see the
defense claiming mental illness and try
to use that as a defense yeah i think
it'd be an interesting defense
especially in a case like this because
what else could be the reason for he
doing such a horrible horrible act with
to so many people and maybe something
that actually is successful in this type
of case but of course we'll continue to
cover this trial or potential trial and
give you the updates as they continue
switching now to new hampshire to a case
that's gained national attention that of
missing seven-year-old harmony
montgomery as the focus now moves to the
state's child welfare agency harmony was
reported missing late last year by her
mother who had lost custody of the girl
because of substance abuse issues she
was last seen in 2019. the child was in
the custody of her father adam
montgomery he told police he gave
harmony back to her mother he faces
charges arising from how he allegedly
treated harmony including second-degree
assault for allegedly punching her in
the eye in 2019 as well as endangering
the welfare of a child and interfering
with custody the reward for information
leading to harmony has reached a hundred
and twelve thousand dollars and the new
hampshire division of children youth and
families is now under investigation at
the tail end of a coven 19 press
briefing wednesday the state's governor
said the agency is quote pulling out
every stop they can to assist in the
investigation
and a florida man accused of killing his
wife three children and the family dog
will wait a few months longer for his
case to go to trial after it was delayed
again at a hearing on wednesday anthony
todd is charged with four counts of
first-degree murder and one count of
animal cruelty for allegedly killing his
wife megan their children 13-year-old
alec eleven-year-old tyler and
four-year-old zoe and the family dog
breezy at their celebration florida home
in january 2020. federal authorities and
local deputies were at todd's home to
arrest him on insurance fraud charges
related to his physical therapy business
while there they found the bodies of his
wife children and the dog wrapped in
blankets investigators believe they have
been stabbed and given toxic amounts of
benadryl todd confessed killing in three
separate interrogations in jailhouse
letters he later blamed his wife for the
slayings the trial was set to begin next
week but after the sudden death of
todd's attorney and a medical issue on
todd's end it was postponed a new trial
date will be set at a hearing on january
21st
still ahead on law and crime daily a
civil lawsuit filed against the district
in the deadly michigan high school
shooting but first a 13 year old's life
cut short how civil rights attorney ben
crump is getting involved in the death
of stanley davis iii
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily fame
civil rights attorney ben crump and
associates assist in a wrongful death
lawsuit after 13 year old florida boy
dies just one day after christmas
it happened in boynton beach florida
when stanley davis iii also known as sj
was riding his dirt bike on a highway an
officer tried to pull davis over saying
the boy was driving erratically that's
when davis lost control of his bike he
died as a result of the crash the name
of the officer involved has not yet been
released but ben crump associate suen
robinson tells me he has been involved
in a couple high-speed pursuits that
have resulted in death
what is that litigation going to look
like in in
what are you asking is done to the
officer
we're asking for the officer to be taken
off duty i think when an officer has
been involved in multiple
pursuits that have ended in fatalities
they and
investigations are ongoing then he he
shouldn't be on the street he shouldn't
be permitted to continue to be in a
position to endanger other people in the
community and unfortunately the boynton
police department has permitted this
officer to continue to be on active duty
to be on the street and it resulted in
him interacting with
stanley
davis iii on the on the day that we're
all here discussing and the issue with
respect to pattern and practice is just
that if this officer has been involved
in multiple pursuits that's ended in
death why is he still out there why is
he on the road while these
investigations are pending he shouldn't
be
i also spoke with sj's father stanley
davis jr who says his son was well
beyond his years and that the department
should be held responsible
they gave very little information so i
don't know as much
i'm just seeking for him to be held
accountable at the end of the day like
say this isn't the first time
this isn't the second time this is the
third time resulting in the death but
there's been many more other incidents
that he's been involved with me back
from this community i know i'm seeing
them every day
so at the end of the day it's just time
for change like in the days
it's like if it don't stop now it's
gonna continue and unfortunately i had
to be my son my child to be the
sacrifice but at the end of the day i
feel like this should be the last child
to have to sacrifice their life because
of his negligence
in a statement the boynton police
department says it will conduct an
internal affairs investigation the
florida highway patrol and a county
medical examiner are also performing
separate investigations let's bring back
legal analyst dina dahl and terry austin
to discuss the civil lawsuit on behalf
of stanley davis iii
terry how troubling is it that this
officer has a history of chases that
result in at least a few deaths uh at
least according to krump
you know brian it's extremely troubling
he was involved in a 2012 high speed
chase that killed a black man and
another high-speed chase in 2016 that
ended up killing a five-year-old boy so
you really have to question whether or
not he's reckless and whether he needs
to continue working on the police force
you know witnesses actually said they
did not see this teenager driving
erratically and i actually viewed a
security camera and he did not seem as
though he was driving erratically so the
police are investigating it they say
there's no dash cam but look it's a
tragic case no matter how you look at it
now do you know what facts do you think
we are missing and we need in this
investigation to get to a point of
transparency and accountability
well i think it's important why he was
following him to begin with like terry
said i also watched the video i don't
see him driving reckless at all so if
that's the case and he was just you know
basically chasing after this boy that's
going to be important also in terms of
his other traffic stops does he have a
history of stopping people you know for
false reasons in addition to those other
fatalities that can be important on the
defensive side what's also important is
how well did this boy know how to ride
this dirt bike evidently he had just
gotten as a christmas gift the day
before they could argue that he just
lost control because he didn't know it
that well so his history how often he
rode this kind of vehicle could be
important as well absolutely we'll get
as we get more information in that
investigation we will report it here on
loan crime daily thank you both
and on the heels of her guilty
conviction former silicon valley titan
elizabeth holmes will spend the next
nine months a free woman without while
out on bail this after a judge set her
sentencing for late september holmes was
the founder and ceo of theranos a blood
testing company once believed to have
revolutionary technology on january 3rd
after a months-long trial and a week of
jury deliberation holmes is found guilty
of four fraud related charges they stem
from homes defrauding investors and
lying about theranos's capabilities
holmes was acquitted of all of the
charges related to patients involved in
testing at theranos the former ceo faces
up to 80 years behind bars a max of 20
years per count her sentencing is set
for september 26 more than a year after
her trial began
coming up on law on crime daily a
monumental ruling by the supreme court
of the united states what that means for
president biden's vaccine mandate plus a
civil lawsuit filed against the oxford
high school district what court
documents allege accused shooter ethan
crumbly brought to school
[Music]
welcome back a new lawsuit is filed in
michigan against the oxford high school
district where a student opened fire
killing four classmates and injuring
seven others back in november the
lawsuit says administrators put students
in danger by downplaying the actions of
accused gunman ethan crumbly ahead of
the shooting it also alleges crumbly
posted quote countdowns and threats of
bodily harm and brought a severed bird
head to school in a jar at the time the
school emailed parents saying there was
no threat to the building or students
the morning of the shooting a teacher
saw concerning drawings of a gun bullet
and a person bleeding on the 15 year old
suspect's desk his parents james and
jennifer crumbly who are facing related
manslaughter charges were called into
the school about the concerning drawings
they are accused of ignoring warning
signs ethan plead not guilty to
first-degree murder assault with intent
to murder and terrorism causing death
charges at his arraignment on wednesday
next up will be a status conference set
for next week to determine a later date
for a hearing
back again to break down the civil
litigation surrounding the tragedy in
oxford high school is legal analyst dina
dahl and co-host terry austin terry can
you explain what the civil lawsuit is
claiming and what it means to prove in
order to be successful
yes this is a wrongful death action
which actually i expected the plaintiff
has to demonstrate negligence and
basically say that the defendant caused
the death of another and here there are
multiple signs that the school might
have been negligent and that ethan
crumbly would have taken some kind of
action that resulted in someone's death
the school either missed it or dismissed
it and there were so many signs the
computer searches the disturbing
drawings the bird's head in a jar and
even the social media post and frankly
they failed to dismiss him from school
and i think that was the biggest mistake
so the list goes on the suit demands 100
million dollars and i expect this will
be the first of many suits yeah now dean
i understand the major difference is the
parents purchase the gun but with
allegations like this and the parents
being charged criminally could the
potentially see the administrators in
the school charge two
so the difference in criminal and civil
negligence is essentially did the person
act unreasonable or reckless i think
terry's right there's quite a lot of
evidence that the school acted
unreasonable but in terms of reckless i
actually think an important piece of
information would be whether or not the
school asked the parents if he owned a
gun i don't think that's come out yet
one it seems that would be a very
reasonable question was it reckless for
them not to have to ask that question
here he is depicted gun he's searching
for ammunition again we don't know if he
they asked or if they were perhaps even
lie to you about the parents so more
will come out but that is the
distinction we'll be looking at all
right we'll see how that information
comes in thank you both this week on
prime crime a case that captivated the
nation host jesse weber takes on the
infamous chris watts story he joins us
now with a look ahead to this week's
episode jesse
hey there brian on our next episode we
tackle the infamous chris watts story
now this is the colorado man who
publicly pleaded for his family's safe
return when they suddenly disappeared
but as the investigation played out it
became clear he was holding back
something big i have no idea like where
they went
and it doesn't it's just earth
shattering i don't feel like this is
even real right now it's like a
nightmare that i just can't wake up from
his behavior during the porch interview
was really interesting
he vacillates from being really calm
verbally to being really fidgety and
kind of rocking back and forth
that rocking shows the uneasiness
bella was going to start kindergarten
he talks in the past tense about one of
his daughters the way that he talks
about his children
is as if he's grieving them and it's
like i want her back so bad i want those
kids back so bad
he kept repeating i just want them back
i just want them back
and there was no real plea for
their safety you know what happened to
them there were no tears there was no
emotion it came out very cool
from his media interviews to a strange
encounter with a neighbor and of course
his police interrogation you can watch
it all unfold on law and crime
thanks jesse you can catch this week's
episode of prime crime friday night at 5
30 p.m and 10 30 p.m eastern time
when we come back the supreme court
makes a ruling on the biden
administration's vaccination mandate how
the ruling affects you after the break
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
leader of the oath keepers is arrested
and charged with seditious conspiracy as
the january 6 investigation unfolds
the fbi arrested stuart rhodes leader of
the far-right oath keepers militia on
thursday 10 others were also arrested
these charges mark the first for the
some 700 people accused of being
involved in last year's insurrection on
the u.s capitol
and the supreme court halts the biden
administration's covet 19 vaccine or
test mandate for private companies with
more than 100 employees
on thursday justices ruled the
administration overstepped in attempting
to impose the osha rule that would
require all employees must be vaccinated
or submit a negative coven 19 test
weekly at the same time scotus ruled
that vaccination mandate will stand for
most health care workers right now the
supreme court has a conservative
majority following the ruling president
biden made a statement calling for
states and businesses to voluntarily
impose a vaccine mandate
dina how did the majority get to their
decision and where does that leave
private businesses with over 100
employees
essentially what they said was that this
regulation didn't address occupational
hazards that this was really a public
health issue and so it wasn't applicable
for osha they did allow it for health
care workers there's a precedent for
that health care workers have had
vaccine mandates
prior to covet and they're accepting
federal money medicaid money so if
they're going to be willing to accept
medicare they can require vaccination
they court did allow that the government
could come back and more narrowly tailor
it maybe perhaps that factory workers or
workers that have to be in close spaces
we'll see if that happens where it
leaves the companies for now is they're
going to have a patchwork of state and
city laws which is going to be difficult
for national companies to apply any kind
of vaccine mandate that they may now
want
now terry the descent obviously
dissented but how do they view the case
so justices briar sodomiter and kagan
all dissented they said that the
conservative majority seriously
misapplied the applicable legal standard
and at issue here as dina said was
whether osha applied and whether or not
osha had the power to impose the
requirements under this 1970 law the
dissent said yes and the majority said
no and of course the majority rule so we
see here that the dissent made a case
but it wasn't a big enough case to
convince the rest of the court so the
biden administration does not have the
power to do this all right we'll see how
this legal battle continues as dina said
it could come back with some nearly
terror
statements or information but we'll see
how it plays out thank you for joining
us here at law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you